[Music]
let's go out to yip saleny Michigan and
talk to chase what's up
Chase not much just living the dream how
about yourself do y' all dream in Yip
Salan yes sir excellent we all dream and
Yips salant what's up
dude oh well first off just big thank
you I appreciate all that you and your
team do you guys are a big blessing to
so many people it's a privilege to be on
the show I appreciate it I do most of
the work the team kind of just that's
that's not true they all look at me like
oh really we can turn this off right
now yeah you win as a team right it's 90
well I lose by myself they yeah we all
win as a team um it's about 98% them 2%
me for sure so what's up
dude um so the question I want to bring
to you is uh so how can I rebuild
healthy habits and routines that I
fumbled since Co started and have lacked
the motivation to return to tell me
about it so as as a bit of backstory so
in 2019 I started grad school and when
Co locked down happened obviously I was
in the middle of my second semester oh
jeez and with that yeah with with
everything moving online like I lost the
intentionality I had with like healthy
eating and with exercise and it resulted
in me gaining 60 pounds and I've still
kind of had a tough time uh returning to
to some of those healthy habits like um
and even with even my my career being uh
online I I wake up five minutes before
my day at work starts and so like it's
it's I'm still kind of on this this
rebuilding path here but like uh and and
as another thing on top of that my wife
and I had a baby uh who's five months
old now and uh she's the alive of my
life couldn't be happier but also you
know with a baby that also makes it a
little bit more difficult to feel like I
can break away and uh and do things like
exercise
um and it's it's really important to me
that I want to be a good example of
healthy decisions and healthy habits to
my baby and to all the others that we
have and so like I it's it's important
to me to want to rebuild some of those
habits that I lost because I I've been
struggling with the motivation to get
back on back uh get back on the horse
awesome man well I man dude thanks for
the call and I'm proud of you for
catching this right and you're doing
what most people don't do is like the
smoke is kind of clearing this is your
new life you work from home um the last
few years have been chaotic you've been
married you have a kid so one of these
years was your wife being pregnant yall
dreaming and then you working and all
that so um but I'm I'm proud of you dude
for going up to the top of the hill and
looking over the clouds and the smoke
and going okay I get to decide what
happens
next okay thank you um that's tough and
I know it's like oh dude bro and then
David Goggins is like who's going to
carry the boats and you're like I dude I
what what like so I'm proud of you right
um I want to talk through a few things
and kind of dig in a little bit is that
okay for sure and I'll give I'll give
you some tactical things thing thing
number
one hard
question why don't you like
chase that is a hard question but but
you know the answer why don't you like
Chase I think that it's
like I I hold on I've strugg hold on you
don't like Chase
why you're good at not answering that
question because you're very very kind
and you're very
smart why don't you like
Chase I don't like that chase is
overweight and that he's not doing
enough to to correct that issue okay
what's beneath
that um
I would say like
some Fame I guess that um I can't seem
to keep a regular exercise routine that
I can't you know put my foot down when
it comes to the things that I eat and um
to kind of take the rein on those
decisions I that's something that I
struggle with and I think that builds
some shame yeah but what's what about
the shame beneath that here here's the
here's the signal you gave me that
there's something else I think those
things are important I've experienced
both of those myself and I think those
are signals those are lights on the
dashboard of a more challenging
issue you are sleeping your light Life
Away you're distracting you're avoiding
your own
life why are you building a life why
have you inadvertently unintentionally
built a life where Chase can avoid Chase
you sleep right up until the moment that
you got to work you work from home all
the way up until you get done with that
you love that little baby until she has
to go back to Mom because five month old
babies don't really give a crap about
their dad except they kind of do nervous
system wise but not in
reality and then you either have a beer
or you sit on the and you and your wife
eat together and that's your romantic
time so of course your body brings you
back that's the only connection point
you have with your wife anymore is meals
and then you either watch a TV show or
you just go to
bed
Fair that's fair so you've built a life
and this isn't on purpose your body in
an effort to protect you has built a
life where you don't have to deal with
Chase that's why underneath the weight
gain underneath the lack of motivation
underneath the lack of
discipline there's this ticker tape
running under the story of your life
under the movie of your life that says
Chase kind of sucks what is
that
I'm not sure like I feel
like I feel like it could be like
the maybe the the hopes and dreams that
I have for myself in terms of personal
development that I'm not attaining I
don't know like
um because like we're we're relatively
new to this area we're nowhere near
family and um and so like it's it's
tough to build friends and with and
since I'm not hanging out with a lot of
people and my wife works sometimes and
stuff and so I'm like I feel stuck at
home and what's a different word for
that what's a a word that men don't say
out
loud I'll say it sounds like you're
lonely
man are you are you doing well
financially is this was this a good move
for
you yeah I mean we're we're very blessed
financially we just became debt free
last month so financially we're we're
doing great was there a sense that when
I made X dollar and I'm got job why that
I would feel a certain way and it's a
Dawning on you after grad school after
you're starting this work from home
job that you went with
you I think that like the the
discrepancy and like the mental picture
is is socially and and tying back to
that loneliness you mentioned I guess
cuzz like working from home you know you
don't build many in-person relationships
you don't have like a a built-in kind of
friend Network like at work and then I
get home and you know I'm with the two
people in my life who I love the most
but also like I just I don't have
anybody else to like just pick up and
say hey let's let's go do X activity
together something like that like and so
I I can see where that loneliness ties
into that too okay cool all right so
here's what we're going to do we are
going to stop waiting on
motivation here's the the weird lie
about
motivation that well I'll just I'll just
reverse engineer it you do a bunch of
stuff over a period of time that you
don't like
doing and then you see some results from
it and then you begin to feel a
different way you going to feel good and
then your body says let's do more of
that so strangely we often wait for
motivation to do a thing we wait for
motivation to change our sex life we
wait for motivation to be nicer to our
wife or to be a better wife to our
husband like I'm gonna you know when he
starts doing this then I'm going to
start doing instead of just hammering it
making it a discipline issue versus a
motivation motivation issue the
motivation
comes it always does but it wains it
goes up and it goes down and what so
I've had to learn the hard way
motivation gets zero zero votes in my
life none zero I love it when it shows
up because it makes what I'm trying to
do easier whether I'm writing or whether
I'm trying to be a better husband or I'm
plugging in with my kids um or trying to
take care of my health but most of the
time it doesn't show up most of the time
it's just annoying right so it gets
literally zero votes in my
life the second thing is you probably
heard me say this on the show a lot from
a personal conversation I had with Sal
de Stefano from mind
pump
you cannot shame or hate your body into
better
shape he told me this privately and it
was so profound for me after second PhD
I had all this psychology all this
whatever and I'd sat with a number of
hurting people and no one had ever
communicated this in the way that he did
he said if you go to the gym or try to
not eat a piece of cake one
time because you you think I'm fat and
gross and I don't want to be fat and
gross you will always run out of
steam because you can't shame or hate
your way into anything productive
period he said if you flip it around and
wake up every day and practice
saying I love myself enough to be a good
husband and a good dad and I love myself
enough that I get one hour
I'm so lucky that I get to get up today
that I was on the wakeup roll cosmically
I'm so lucky that that little girl gets
to gets got me as a dad I get an
hour I get to invest an hour in me
because I'm worth that and he said if
you flip that around and you make it a
stewardship issue versus a not being so
disgusting issue dude you can go
forever okay if you you if you if you
invest money if you save
money and you hate every second of
saving you're not going to save very
long if you save money with the intent
of your grandkids
smiling through their tears after your
funeral when they see The Inheritance D
that's a whole other ball game
right yeah it's just a different way to
look at it here's the third thing you
are going to have to do the opposite of
what most people do the greatest gift
you can give your daughter right now is
not 247 365 access to her dad the
greatest gift you can give your daughter
is you go make some
friends the greatest gift you can give
your daughter is to go to the gym and
normally I tell people to get a gym at
their house I think you need the
opposite I think you need to go
somewhere and probably start going to a
couple of
classes okay and I'm not even into
classes I think this is just an easy way
for you to to be accountable for a
season and you're going to show up and
you're going to start seeing some of the
same faces and I want you to go be weird
cuz part of you or a big part of you is
going to want to hide I'm 60 pounds
overweight I'm an embarrassment I jiggle
when I jump I don't look right you see
what I'm saying but you're not going to
do that yeah you're GNA go hey what's up
man my name's
Chase and they're gonna go awesome good
to see you dude you are kicking button
here you are too man
sweet and you're just going to go be
weird I wish there was another way to do
it dude there just not
but you've got to make decisions to be
away from your home instead of always
there okay does that make sense yes sir
and I hate that for you and don't if you
don't want to take classes and just go
LIF weights that's that's
fine uh another thing you can do is just
put your daughter in a stroller and take
her for walks around the neighborhood
during breaks at
work do you ever do
that yeah and and especially on days
where my wife works she's a nurse and
she works works like from afternoon to
late at night and so I'll usually take
her on walks uh usually the days that
she works and then I kind of I I kind of
lose that when she's at home because
we're all together and things get
distracting but yeah I I'm intentional
about walks when my wife that work let's
change that language you allow things to
get
distracting but when your wife gets home
y' all can all three go for a walk and I
know it because we I did it even when I
was
exhausted me and my wife and my son me
and my wife and my
daughter that's not the same as as a
weightlifting ex like series season but
it's something and it kind of brings you
and your wife back together instead of
just in front of the TV most couples
spend most of their together time in
front of a television
set right and that's not real intimacy
it's just proximal um here's what I'm
going to do I'm going hook you up a
couple things um number one um I'm going
to hook you up with
the um weight loss app that I use my
friend Dr Lane Norton it's the best one
in the business it's called carbon it's
what I use every single day of my life
okay uh H Andy hberman uses it like it's
what people use it's incredible and I'm
going to give it to you for a year okay
um hang on the line here and we're going
to get you set up the other thing I'm
going to give you is my friends at mind
pump will give you any of their workouts
that you would like any of them again
they're workouts that I use I give to my
personal friends okay and you can go
through it and pick it and I think it
would be excellent excellent excellent
the third thing is I want you do you
have
Instagram no sir okay I can't believe
I'm recommending this but I want you
actually don't do it don't do it but I
want you to go on YouTube and I want you
to follow my friend Jordan s s y a
TT he makes funny videos and he does
swear a lot so you're going to have to
just shake that off probably don't watch
it in front of your kid but he is a a
great human being B one of the most
knowledgeable guys in the industry and
he has made some
videos dude and I I just am privilege to
rub shoulders with some of the smartest
guys in the industry who I have their
personal cell number I call them and
they walk me through things and he has
made some videos that is just like a
light bulb for
me okay and I want you to follow Jordan
s y a
those three that gang the Mind pump guys
Dr Norton and Jordan
scatt will give you the tools both on a
daily basis with Jordan's videos the
actual tools for Dr Norton's carbon app
and the mind pump guys and and listen I
get I have no Financial affiliation with
these dudes I don't get one penny from
anything I'm just telling you this is
what I use in my
house as a guy who struggled with my
weight struggled with shame struggled
struggled with
um even knowing if I'm hungry or not but
my body just eats when I get stressed
two seeing a baby a little baby that I
love more than life itself but I don't
know what I'm doing and I get
scared right that shame my wife seems to
just know how to do all this stuff and I
don't know how to do any of it and so I
just hide except you don't have an
office to go to you have another room
which makes it weird
right right well and thank you that's
all very generous I appreciate that well
here's the deal um I want you the only
thing I ask in return is in 30 days I
want you to have actually used this
stuff and in 30 days won't you write me
back and let me know where you
are okay and the scale is just a part of
that the scale is just going to be
reflective of it's the dashboard for
Chase has
decided he's worth living a better
life he's worth feeling really good he's
worth sleeping really good he's worth
not snoring anymore he's worth modeling
in front of his kids
and by the way if you don't want to go
if you'd rather work out at home and
model that for your kid
awesome I personally think the five
months to a year I think you're good
going for six months to a gym meeting
new people seeing how things go even if
you find a trustworthy personal trainer
that's going to show up that you're
going to have to pay for I think that's
worth it if it's one of if it's a
personal trainer clown and the mind pump
guys have some good things you can
Google about what's a good train or not
there's clowns out there but there's
clowns every and every industry also
some really amazing folks but give
yourself the accountability but go out
and make
Community invite people from your local
church invite people from the gym invite
you have your wife invite some of her
nursing friends and their husbands over
go be intentionally weird this is me
telling you to stop smoking except I'm
going to tell you stop doing loneliness
stop being
alone and I wish there was an easy path
forward they're just not just got to go
it's hard and you got to go be
weird but metal lesson people listening
to this don't wait for motivation it
will not show up it won't show up or it
might like a like a bolt of lightning
and then it goes
away lean on discipline lean on a choice
that I'm going to tell myself the truth
because I am
trustworthy and I'm going to get up
every day and make a choice to to move
my body I'm gon to get up every day and
make a choice to plug in with my wife
and say how can I love you today I'm
going to wake up every day and hold that
baby's face and just look directly into
its eyes I'm going to wake up every day
and decide I'm going to eat
right make those choices don't wait on
motivation you got this Chase thanks for
your
call